ladies and gentlemen i'm excited for
this one today we're talking about a
conversation that was leaked to me
uh via an anonymous tip and it's a
conversation between two scammers and it
allows us a rare look
into how they think how you can spot
them
and more importantly the kind of trash
that's being allowed
promulgated pushed on instagram all the
time people trying to
get you to hand over your money in a new
way you guys all know about the nigerian
prince but you don't know about a lot of
these investment scams now this is gonna
be a two-part series because today we're
talking about
the inside look at their dms their
conversation when no one's watching
the second is a confrontation between
myself
and this scammer where i try to get to
the heart of what this person is doing
how they feel about the scam
and ultimately a scammer's perspective
on the victims of a scam it's
fascinating i think you will find it
very interesting if you like psychology
if you like any kind of like true crime
stuff this is
an insane inside look at this um and you
rarely get that
so starting off let's talk about who's
involved there are two people david
ferris
fx which is actually a cover that's not
his real name this is a fake account
that is made to lure investors in to
invest with this person
between this guy and another guy named
stocks college
here it is right here number one stock
market training program 500 plus
satisfied students top-rated funds
okay trying to get this social proof
going on right they're constantly
posting about trades stuff like that
you see accounts like this all the time
now let me say right off the bat one of
these accounts has since been deleted
that would be david ferris
fx which is why i wanted to compare it
to a
similar um probably almost identical
account
called invest with hilda fx very similar
forex expert
binary trader entrepreneur all this kind
of stuff uh
dme let's earn huge profits
so this is basically what david ferris
was doing he's posting daily about forex
all these trades all this money
but that's who we're dealing with so
let's set the tone it starts off
i hope our conversation don't get leaked
we should chat somewhere private do you
have whatsapp
i'm gonna blur out that number for uh
privacy reasons and this guy goes what
happened to your personal page i can't
find it
blocked you why would you do that bro
you keep changing ig accounts you making
it hard to do business with you
safety bro my main page never changes so
this david ferris
fx scammer is basically saying i have
two accounts one for the scam
one that's completely unassociated and
stocks college
is upset because he can't get a hold of
him but david ferriss's reasoning is
pretty clear
imagine police stops me and go through
my instagram i'm
stocks college responds lowell they
can't go through your instagram
david ferris what google sars nigeria
they kill scammers bro now for those of
you wondering sars
is the special anti-robbery squad which
is a nigerian-based police force
which has some extremely controversial
methods
of uh of enforcement as you can see here
they've been linked to acts of
extortion torture framing and blackmail
and basically a lot of people in nigeria
want them shut down
this guy's afraid of sars the
conversation goes on
okay man anyways they can go through
your whatsapp too then
david ferris responds i've got two
phones
one of them is scam free which is
extremely interesting and this guy
feels pretty sophisticated uh compared
to probably a lot of scammers who don't
go through all these hoops to try to
stay
you know clean as far as their public
image is concerned but then this guy
goes i don't know bro you're doing too
much and i'm confused i need you for the
scam
this is stocks college a instagram page
that is still
up still trying to i guess get people to
invest i don't know
do you want to make money or not he says
yeah i want to make money
but without using my official page dude
i don't understand i'm using robert
demayo's picture on a new page
nice man i need to make multiple ig
accounts and post on all of them grow
all of them yeah you can do that so
they're talking about diversifying for
when they have to burn one of these
accounts you want multiple
so moving on they go yeah great job man
when someone message you bitcoin
what do you do david ferris responds i
give them a good format
talk to them like a company or an
organization lead them on and give them
everything legit because i know they'll
want to verify all i'm saying
it will be them that will ask to send
their money
how's everything going great over here
urines chilling man trying to collect as
many investors as i can
any word from the naveen guy i guess
that's one of their leads he then sends
them some car
and then we have our scammer going damn
last night i was so visualizing myself
in
s-class bins now let's stop for a second
and say this is what all scammers do all
of them
by very much into this manifestation
idea they think that if they think it
they will do it they get it all from the
secret they all believe in it like
totally
so you'll see a lot of that on this
channel david ferris says delete your
comment bro i guess he's referring to
some kind of post maybe on his private
instagram
i deleted it why you want me to delete
the comment lol
i just feel in case your followers see
it they shouldn't know your movements so
again we find david ferris is constantly
trying to elude detection he doesn't
want anyone to see who he is
later in the conversation we see more of
this sort of paranoid behavior
cool man bro did you block the persuade
guy lol yeah of course i blocked
apparently this is probably someone who
invested with them asking for returns
uh and they just block them that's how
this stuff works you invest
and they keep you on the hook until you
ask for your money back they promise you
these super high returns
uh and when you do ask for it back they
block you
lol for real the worst is still to come
who the is that loser though damn bro
you're savage no dude you're a scammer
and now all of your dirty laundry is
being exposed how about that
joke's on you guys now stocks college
says i'm gonna block him too
yup block is he's a past so this guy
goes stocks college says i'm gonna grow
five new pages and buy established pages
and cash
out bro each account we can make easy
80k they're talking about scamming
raise 30 to 40 commission 30 to 40 and
extra like you did with persuade here
and there and that's it
burn the account so this is the
mechanism behind this stuff and i hope
you guys are thinking
wow i'm never going to invest in an
instagram
investor ever and you shouldn't because
the chances are
they're scamming just like these people
are look at what this guy's talking
about we can do
three to four a year maybe or more not
sure
let's see how it goes different pages
just like stock college just different
name
and brand i will post daily content on
those like i do here
grow organic following and people then
cash out when i do a fundraise
so again they post a ton of content and
they say guys i'm starting a fund
i'm going to make all this money you're
going to make 200 you're going to make
500
and they steal it and here's where we're
gonna see a post from stocks college of
this scam in
action so they put up these stories this
is uh stocks college
almost full thank you to everyone who
invested and it says i'm raising 30k to
trade
and once i reach it it's capped don't
ask me after please
50 50 split on these daily profits you
see on my page so this is what he's
talking about right here
13 000 a thousand dollars he's talking
about
all these uh pages supposedly where he's
making all this money
he's saying you could split the profits
of course this is all a lie he's gonna
burn the account eventually
but this is how he raises the money and
he's talking here to this guy
mr persuade who they were talking about
earlier about blocking
and here it says bro if robert gives me
my profits i'm
in in other words this guy's already
invested and he wants to invest
again but he hasn't received his profits
back so he's saying hey pay me first and
then i'll
join your new fun that you're
fundraising right and what do they do
they block the guy as you can see laugh
laugh laugh
laugh laugh look at these scumbags dude
can you imagine doing this to somebody
this
looks so legit he still can't find the
scam in it they're talking about mr
persuade
trust bro we are crazy and this is
really insidious okay this is where
these guys do
understand psychology really well he
says let it seem like he's the only one
who hasn't received his profits the
reason why this business will hold well
is the fact that each person will think
that they are the only one that have
problems
especially when they see you posting
profits and payouts to different clients
this
is sick guys this is how the scam
works it's gas lighting it's fakery
it's lying this is what they do they're
experts
at it and again where does this thrive
on instagram where you don't have to be
anybody to post all these profits to say
you're such a millionaire trader they're
posting fake screenshots of the trader
i mean i don't know if i showed you guys
this but stocks college has an
image of their trader that's not
actually the guy look at this
they say senior trader located in
toronto canada no he's not
this guy isn't real this guy is a fake
profile to lure you in again it's all
manipulated it's
all a fraud and here's where the scam
continues
look at this every time a person is
ready to pay out i'll send them to you
so like i said
david ferris is sort of like uh the
in-man stocks college is the middle man
he says make sure to get a testimonial
and everything before you block them i
can use that as content so what they say
is before we pay you out
we need a testimony people naively do it
thinking that they're gonna about to get
paid out like 500 percent
they post it as if they paid it out and
then blocked that person so they can't
post anymore
this does two things like they're saying
first of all
it shows everybody else in the group
they think
oh yeah people are getting paid out no
they're not number two
it gaslights everybody thinking that
they're the only one who didn't get paid
out
okay so we're gonna fast forward a
little bit just because some of these
dm's are
uninteresting bro bro bro bro that kind
of stuff
then they start talking about burning
the account remember they're gonna
build a bunch of accounts like stocks
college and then burn them when they go
when basically they get called out
caught or you know too many investors
get burned
so david ferris is talking to him if
you're gonna burn it it won't be now at
all
okay i will see how it goes i'm gonna
burn it in three or four months when
everyone asks for a payout i'm gonna do
another fundraise in between this one
while i show people the investors
accounts profit again
they haven't actually gotten the money
but it's like allegedly what's in their
account it's a big ponzi scheme
then this david faro's hatch has an idea
pay one or two of them 2k
and collect videos and screenshot and
post it up so then this guy's kind of
getting he goes oh
so whoever didn't get in will get in yes
they will invest again and bring more
friends
oh yeah so it's almost like an
undetectable ponzi scheme
plan your date and then pay investors
who invested little
it's a small price to pay for the big
gains since the other investors
will be willing to pay the commission so
again this is
uh kind of diabolical what they're
saying is anybody who invested a little
like a hundred dollars maybe they're
promising like 2 000
returns something crazy like that you
actually pay them out the 2k
that they're owed collect videos and
then
attract new investors this is diabolical
and why this is important to note
is that you might may find an instagram
account
that's supposedly paying out investors
that supposedly has
real testimonials right you don't know
that they're not doing this behind the
scenes right
secretly only paying out a few burning
everybody else
to try to keep the ponzi scheme going a
lot of people do that especially
scammers on instagram and again look at
how gleeful these people
are there's no morality here at all
there's no thought of
we're ripping people off we're ruining
people's lives
look at this they're just so happy about
it we are controlling the narrative by
having multiple outs
nice you're smart as hell perfect man
one guy gave me a hundred dollars i'll
give him 300 and they're laughing
again guys this is a sickness affecting
people who number one they might not
have
other prospects in life maybe that's why
they feel the need to skim but i think
the other part of it is
they watch how little of this stuff is
prosecuted how much does instagram crack
down on these accounts
almost none uh how much does instagram
take accountability for these actions
or report them to law enforcement almost
none
so when this happens they're not scared
look at this they're just gleeful
okay thanks bro you're the guy helping
me you're my only partner so good job we
have a huge future
and that's basically it actually that's
about where the conversation
ends so i hope you learned something let
me know what you think in the comments
below about content like this
i really enjoyed getting in the minds of
these people and tomorrow
we will not only be getting into the
minds of this person we are
actually contacting him i confronted
david ferris fx he deleted his account
but i contacted his whatsapp number and
i just wanted to talk
thanks for watching and as always don't
forget to smash
like and subscribe thank you
[Music]
soccer
comes along